là messieurs bonsoir depuis ce matin la
plupart d'entre vous paie plus cher
leurs consultations médicales s'était en
effet à partir d'aujourd'hui que la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
avait appelé ses adhérents à une
augmentation sauvage des honoraires en
général 5 francs de plus pour la
consultation du généraliste soit 45
francs les négociations sur le
renouvellement la convention ne
reprendront qu'après demain
pour l'instant elles sont dans l'impasse
et il est évident que la sécurité
sociale ne remboursera pas au patient
cette augmentation décidée
unilatéralement par les médecins alors
comment réagissent les uns et les autres
le reportage d'isabelle bechler je
trouve que quand même c'est d'accord
puisque tout le monde n'y a pas de
raison que les dr knock maintenant mais
la route côté y en a qui exagèrent qui
prennent vraiment trop cher lorsqu'il
n'est pas logique c'est que si l'on
n'est pas en danse est intégralement et
on va par la sécurité sociale
est-ce que vous changeriez de médecins
pour en trouver en moins cher je crois
que les gens ne regardera pas une petite
somme pour changer du médecin c'est le
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir le médecin qui
beaucoup plus plus intéressant qui
suivit qu'il faut nous qui connaît le
malade et tout ce qui s'ensuit
bien sûr on peut s'étonner de cette
relative résignation des malades mais il
faut savoir que pour eux la santé ça n'a
pas de prix
de leur côté les médecins ont des
revendications précises à faire valoir
le pouvoir d'achat du corps médical
comme celui des autres catégories ça
c'est pause socioprofessionnelles était
bloqué depuis un an maintenant il était
donc indispensable que nous puissions
appliquer une augmentation de tarif de
noël en tout cas là vous pensez à votre
pouvoir d'achat mais le nôtre celui 10 à
sion et sociaux parce qu'il devient
abordé le problème de cette façon c'est
en fait remettre la question au niveau
que nous aurions voulu qu'elle soit
posée c'est à dire en faire un problème
politique
ce que jusqu'à présent le gouvernement a
strictement refusé de faire je déjà
augmenté mes honoraires au début de
l'année
comme à centrale la fédération des
médecins de france l'avait demandé c'est
à dire qu'au lieu de 40 francs vous fait
payer combien
avant je fais payer 42
et vous patients ne sont pas remboursés
pour cela ils ont deux francs à leur
charge
et comment réagit style je n'ai pas eu
de problème parce que je leur explique
et que leur expliquer vie juridique de
france est une grille de loto
il faudrait augmenter de manière
significative les honoraires peut-être
aux alentours de 50 francs certainement